on this episode we have visitors from
both sides
[Music]
huh
for them this is
he asked Gary B
[Music]
2:31 yes good I ready for this Mary
you're nervous yeah why you nervous I
was getting nervous
I like that are super not nervous Oh
all right ready and hey everybody this
is gary vay-ner-chuk and this is episode
231 of the ask gary vee show and it is
oh it is a ridiculous show this is a
ridiculous show there's a hodgepodge of
things going on there's so many stories
here and we finally got in a show I know
I've been traveling a bunch of we
haven't gotten one in so I'm glad we're
doing that so why don't we do this Jake
when we start with you once you give a
little two to three seconds you know I
know everybody under 35 is gonna know
exactly who you are but I've got some 57
year old so I don't know no it yeah
absolutely they exist oh yeah they're
out there why don't you tell everybody
to 30 minutes about your career it's a
very interesting guy invested in this
company I've known his family for a
little while now but he's an absolute
blueprint to the future and so I'm
excited about you being on the show
Thank You Man Kim two cents yeah what's
up guys I'm Jake Paul I'm a social media
creator I'm an actor and I'm also an
entrepreneur so kind of the three you
know trifecta from Cleveland Ohio moved
out to Los Angeles to pursue
entertainment that led to a multitude of
other things on a Disney Channel show
have like 17 million followers now run a
company called team dumb which has
different divisions which some some of
you might have heard 15:10 um that's
really the culinary how old are you I'm
19
yep that [ __ ] hurt all right we'll
get back to that in a minute now why
don't you guys tell the vaynernation why
you're here and a little bit about
yourselves okay so say hello here
books okay yeah so basically in March we
went to London and we were at the fan
media book launch the ask IV book and we
end up winning a competition we were the
only guys with a chocolate bar left here
it is B no jokes so this was how you
entered into a raffle and this was the
winning video job is that it was hey I
love it
right cuz there was a number on it all
these had numbers and I got a little
Oprah doubt and started giving away
random prizes what was the prize right
before you do know I was it to win a
chit to see the Jets with you I don't
know as well God afters but you guys won
the trip to the US to be on the show
yeah I'm worried and that was you
winning yes say were you excited so
excited my legs are shaking simpler so
you guys are playing India's role today
you're asking the questions yeah good
and what tell everybody a little bit
about your thing and so I know my
cigarettes will involve started about
three years ago and in head and joined
the team about six months ago and we're
especially by marketing company so we
handle newsletters email campaign team
alteration for different businesses
we're a small team so there's a three of
us so high knees back of your face look
at what should protect the exercise room
quickly and hoping to catch up with
immediately you sure mommy baby got
3,000 followers so if you can have this
kappa awesome alright I think this is an
appropriate time to getting into the
show so what is the first question
bs how safe would you play it when faced
with the decision to quit your daytime
job to be an entrepreneur so Jake you
know you're such a young guy you you
didn't go down the route do you ever
have a job like maybe when you're 14 in
like a landscaping company so you were
entrepreneur from the gap yeah there was
no like I'm gonna work at Fatburger in
Cleveland Ohio okay yeah I don't know if
they have fat burgers in Cleveland Ohio
just first company anyway nonetheless so
so did you just were your parents or
grandparents or anyone in your family
entrepreneurs not really no my uncle was
probably the biggest
but didn't like spend a ton of time with
him so kind of just like had the natural
hustle for it I guess um my dad was like
yo you shouldn't get a regular job
because like you're not gonna learn
anything you know if you have a
landscaping company you're gonna learn
how to negotiate so your dad was was
really pushing for yeah he was like you
know how to like you know set the prices
yes get customers get recurring
businesses yep
you know yeah you know I'm gonna look
anything that keeps you up at night is
something that should be addressed and
so if it's really keeping you up at
night like you're not sleeping you're
stressed you're thinking that I'm gonna
have regret my whole life I would take
it very serious and I would play it not
safe at all if you're kind of full of
[ __ ] and once in a while you think about
it and once in a blue moon you think
about it well then I would play it safe
the punchline is this way too many
people are playing it half pregnant you
either do it or you don't
there is no in-betweens and that's the
bottom line when it comes to this this
is binary you know you know I talk about
entrepreneurial tendencies a ton and
that's fine Who am I to judge just cuz I
love entrepreneurship you do you but
this question is silly because you don't
need to ask a question on a show like
this because if you really couldn't
breathe
you wouldn't be doing it and you
wouldn't be worried about my opinion on
it cool let's move on Lukas asks when
did Jake know his following on vine
started to go big and what were three
mistakes he made during the client so
for a lot of you Jake and his brother
were big breakout stars on vine probably
in that group of 40 to 50 60 that really
hit probably they had higher ranks but
I'm just trying to give you a sense of
like how many vine celebrities really
popped when you know when did you start
when did he know that there was
something going on and what were a
couple of mistakes you made yeah so it
kind of all started with one video and
we both like grew like 5,000 followers
so that both of you yeah and that was
like the start of it where we're like oh
my gosh we got followers is the greatest
thing but then from then on we just like
took that viral kind of recipe of
creating a video and replicated it and
that's when like weird gain like 5,000
are you doing a lot of collaborations to
get awareness no because we're in Ohio
right we're in Ohio well what's your
names they're the dancing
and she's awesome we we just could never
like up but yeah just like it's far to
drive in Ohio no driving 30 minutes is
like you don't do that like a 10 minute
drive as far interesting really I would
have thought in like Ohio that like that
would be the reverse I feel like in New
York like one blocks like whoa but like
in Jersey I should drive like 40 minutes
just to my friend's house yeah that's
not how it is Wow I was gangster yeah so
what about mistakes real quick on that
yeah mistakes super important um I think
some of them is I wasn't creating
content like consistently I didn't
realize how important that was huge
um and then I also wasn't always cross
promoting my different socials so like
my vine got to like 5 million followers
and like I would never promote my
Instagram all right then the Instagram
account oh yeah short line so I wish I
would have done that the whole entire
way let me do a recall to my early days
of influencer I actually struggle to
talk about my mistakes it's like one of
the weird things about me and it's like
like it's probably a very flawed thing
but I actually as you were talking
reminded myself of one no question in
oath 607 when I was a YouTube wine thing
that was happening I made the mistake of
even though I knew YouTube was going to
be huge viddler came along and offered
me equity in their company to move my
show on their platform and I took the
better business deal and I gave up the
exposure and and and I've only done that
once because I always value exposure
over everything I do it all the time
it's always long term versus short term
it was such a good deal and I love and
Rob and Collin I love viddler and by the
way it had technology where you could
tag videos and I needed that because I
was making 30 minute videos back when
everybody was making 5 second videos so
made sense but I no question as much as
I want to finagle it I took a short term
upside of a business deal over the
long-term value of the awareness and the
branding so that's something you know
that battle of short and long term is
huge next your a test series I recently
started
a company called where people apparel
should I document the build-up of the
business via Instagram and Facebook
including the behind the scenes stuff or
keep it more professional on the
business page so the question is I've
been talking a lot about documenting
versus creating I watch you I know I
love you uh so what do you think you
think you think what he just said from
your opinion should the business page be
about the business and then what's his
name on his Jared page he's doing kind
of the vlogging and this stuff or do you
think the business page he should
consider the vlogging there what's the
company called it's a clothing apparel
companies Carl I feel like the
documenting of it would be really cool
if it was like about the grind of like
creating uh like if it was like if the
t-shirt company was called like grind or
something like that and then he was
documenting like how to grow that I
don't know for my answer on this I think
it doesn't matter I think of this
similar to names its ironically use the
name like I don't think a name means
anything I think people make names
Google and Facebook and Nike meant
nothing to anybody before they were
executed so to me whether you do it on
your personal page or on the business
page there's some variable differences
coverage will be different different
things will happen
the really net net score at the end of
the day it won't matter people always
ask me like if you build the garyvee
brand does that help vein are in this
stab the other thing net net it's the
steak not the sizzle like if you get
people watching in either direction
people the amount that people actually
pay attention to that little logo
especially when it's a business actually
deteriorates over time it's they're
looking at the content and so either
plan will work for you and I think you
should spend less time crippled by which
one and just start doing yesterday next
question is from Vincent Aaron Jesse
Vincent asks how do you explain to a
potential client or partner the
importance of social media specifically
Facebook when they personally feel they
failed executing in that medium and
don't believe that worth the time and
money investment have you had to have a
conversation business-wise where
somebody paid in it to make it to your
world an influencer where it didn't work
out for them but you were trying to
convince them to work with you or people
you represent
that nature I say that again so the
question that they're asking which is
always interesting because it's actually
a very fascinating question which is hey
how do you convince somebody to invest
in Facebook if you really believe in it
when they come back to you and say well
I've already done Facebook and it didn't
work because that happens to me all the
time and and I always I'll answer it
while you think I just would love your
story mmm I always say we'll listen
what's the ROI of a basketball
I'm gonna go Cleveland Ohio here for me
nothing for LeBron a billion and the
reason I use that analogy is just gonna
keep try Facebook doesn't mean you did
it well yeah like there's a lot of
influencers that have a lot of followers
like you do that I know are a bad buy
and then I know you and a small group
are a good buy because of what you do
with your attention of content 100%
content the message do you align does
your brand
align with that brand have you ever had
to sell somebody on doing something with
an influencer or yourself that said to
you guys well I've done influencer
remarking before and it hasn't worked
has that come up yet yeah all the time
and you just have to punch them in the
face yeah either punch them in the face
or explain to them like why you're
theoretically person right which is hard
if you're fighting a like lost battle
execute it you know it's funny we get to
recall the name executions the variable
right like like again a name you might
think you have the greatest name ever
but if you suck and your business sucks
you lost like here's the punchline for
everybody Facebook works Facebook
advertising works like one of my
favorite quotes is like everything works
not everything works for you like it
works that's it like it's been
documented time and time again that it
works so does television
so does a lot of things Google search
you know influencer marketing it all
works but are you good enough to execute
it for what you're trying to accomplish
for the money that you're allocating
influencer marketing works if your
company needs to sell eighty thousand
pairs of shoes that Jake would promote
and and to make back the money that you
gave him and that's how your think about
your business and he only sold 17,000 in
his promotion for you maybe that didn't
work for you in the short term maybe
those 17,000
pairs of sneakers actually got talked
about by other people and eventually you
sold 97,000 thus all comes down to the
basic theme of short and long-term
strategy was brought up already in the
show that's where you have to weigh out
things but the thought that somebody
back to really answering his question
directly Vincent's like you I think you
know ironically I think Jake and is in
his way absolutely answers it correctly
which is like people tell me like
everything doesn't work that we do and
we still build 100 million dollar
company on it because everything that we
do also works the variable is the
execution the creative you know the
media planning the production like
there's a million variables the timing
what time you post has a variable impact
have you guys ever like as you were
going through it and learning the game
did you realize that hashtags or what
time you would pose or when or when
things were trending thing every little
thing yeah you have their cynicism
I know that they had to live that like
when you become an expert in your domain
everybody thinks that they're gonna be
Jake well I'm gonna make funny videos
I'm gonna make you bit like everybody
thinks are gonna be an influencer until
they realize that a you have that talent
B you have to be a practitioner and
understand all the things that go into
it they Rock everybody's got a D Rock
now you're like you're going to become a
verb or an adjective or I [ __ ] noun I
don't know how that grata my grammar is
not that strong but like everybody's got
a D rock cool great so we're all gonna
be walking around in four years and
everybody's gonna have somebody
following them and filming Mazel Tov but
not everybody's interesting and has
something to [ __ ] say yeah salary
Tyler that's just the way it is I also
say like Ted to answer his question like
I just asked people if they have a TV in
their pocket like you have Facebook in
your pocket a hundred percent you a
hundred percent
cool reddit Oh Jake gets a question yeah
I forget it pick up something that no no
it's a good question though it oh it's
like how do you separate is this
something you actually give a [ __ ] about
yeah okay good how do you separate
business and personal life um like do
you put your phone down completely
do you like are you worried are you
worried about all the dating life
opportunities you have in front of you
no you just can't just find it hard
especially because like to turn off
exactly to turn off do you want to turn
off yeah sometimes okay and do you know
cuz I like I asked it like I went on an
off road trip my dad I was like well
this I'm in like this beautiful area
like I don't have service but I should
still film this and snapchat it
interesting I like posting you feel a
pressure to execute yet yeah I mean I
look I think I think there's an
evolution first of all when you're 19
when you're at three people you're on
fire like it's so early like you want it
so bad like you want it so bad oh and by
the way as now I'm the old guy in this
thing at 40 I still want it so bad
mainly because my ambition is so high I
think it's a very personal question you
know for for me you know the reality is
a lot of these things we talk about them
in theory we answer questions we've got
thoughts but they're very detailed
there's always a nuance in everybody's
life that doesn't say I just do what I
want to do and I never questioned myself
for my actions so I think too many
people [ __ ] some ideological thing on
themselves I should turn off here
because it's so beautiful look at this
beautiful place document it do you know
what I mean like like I don't do that to
myself I don't let anybody and most
importantly even my own points of view
on what I should do dictate how I feel
about myself I just do and then think
about it after the fact
instead of prior which has been a very
very very substantial switch that I have
that has made me very happy to be honest
I'm not judging myself I love myself
like like I love that picture you know
that picture with the the Pope and
everybody's taking picture there's that
one old lady it's like a very famous
picture do you know about this thank you
like um and everyone's like oh she
really captured it like there's a
picture for everybody's watching I
actually throw it up here in the edit
there's a picture here it is where
everybody heralded this lovely old lady
right she actually captured the moment
while everybody else looked at the Pope
through their phone I don't believe that
I actually feel bad for that old lady
I believe that she's already forgotten
it yes right that like that everybody
else actually has it documented and has
a nice asset and I think we are
absolutely going through a very real
time where we demonize technology and we
idolize old and true things because
people hate change
we and I'm about to get really pissed
here because this blows my mind I'll be
there in a minute
we close it we we have somehow put
writing a letter on a pedestal that if I
write you a letter that this is one of
the great things that I can do in
society like oh my god
you are such a lovely person you wrote
me a letter you're so special yet when
we text someone we don't view that as
special we view that as bad we should be
talking to each other what we've done is
we've put a piece of paper and a pen on
a pedestal and we've demonized a phone
but neither matters because they're just
the mediums it's the message inside that
matters you want to say something sweet
and phenomenal to me I don't give a [ __ ]
if you do it through a pen and paper or
via text in emojis it's the intent
behind the love not the [ __ ] medium
[ __ ]
I'm obviously like right like that is
fascinating
so yes great you can put grandma on a
pedestal and say she actually is the
purest form things are changing either
get on board or don't question of the
day I'll let you ask it ask who Gus's me
oh that's in your videos at home but
just in real life questions they ask the
question day any question you want what
do you want the vaynernation to answer
can we do a request sure
it was pretty ballsy yeah I like it yup
good I want to request for anybody who
receives spammy emails oh you don't want
a you're not gonna requests you're going
with a sales pitch even more ballsy go
ahead that's good
study sales emails that just bring
no value we want them to email them and
say get in touch with the wind box so
that we can do your marketing better wow
you really went there huh I'm impressed
take take control of your moment you
came from the UK might as well cut it or
do it any final parts for you
no um I would say I think one of the
questions I saw in the comments was like
they always like watch these videos and
then no-one executes and I would say
like actually like take this information
and run with the wind you know I mean
you've done that like I've you know I'm
an investor and believer in you and your
best in your company because I believe
in you so much because because you're
right
most people don't execute and you have
and so I appreciate that in the 19 I
love it impressive guys thank you for
coming I hope your trip to New York is
awesome you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
[Music]